it's a pretty good market for college
grads coming in but it's never good when
you're the one trying to find a job
because it's really hard here's the
thing about jobs there are three forces
that are at fundamental war with one
another all the time there's the job
quality the job satisfaction the
inherent attributes of the job and that
is are you working on something
fundamentally important and meaningful
are you learning are you growing are you
working with people who you can really
like and respect is the culture or
something you're very comfortable with
all the inherent things about the job
that's one aspect then there's money of
course compensation sometimes is that
very much odds with something that is
genuinely meaningful or creative or
fundamentally interesting and how do you
weigh the differences between looking to
make the kind of money that will help
you pay back student loans much less
live the lifestyle you want to live and
actually I'm speaking of lifestyle
that's the third dimension lifestyle
lifestyle is where you want to live and
where you want to work how much your
work schedule is in your control control
over your work schedule how much
flexibility to take vacations do you
have to commute and how were your actual
hours so if you think about those three
points and what I call the career
triangle job satisfaction money and
lifestyle it's relatively easy to
maximize one point on the triangle and
it's often okay to maximize the second
but usually the third point slips so
you're interested in the law and you get
a good job in a law firm and you're
making good money but you know what you
have to work weekends you have to work
90 hours a week or you're fundamentally
interested in the financial markets and
you're really into deals and you're
working on lots of different things and
also good interest good money but
terrible lifestyle or
no you played college tennis and you
love tennis you love teaching and so
you're really a tennis pro and you have
a great flexible lifestyle but it's hard
to make money that way or you're
passionate about the environment and you
get this great opportunity to work for a
not-for-profit so you're have a good
lifestyle you're working on important
things but you're not making money at
least recognizing that there are
trade-offs is really powerful and what I
like to say is you can have it all those
three dimensions but not necessarily at
the same time and it's certainly not in
your first job or two or three coming
out of college it's okay to be honest
with yourself to say what are the most
important things to me now
and by the way over your life when
you're in your 20s when you're in your
30s when you're raising a family
those are the waiting's on those three
points can can and actually will shift
and actually knowing that will help you
make good career decisions over the
course of your career people graduating
in 2016 and 2017 are going to likely
work for 15 or 20 different companies or
organizations over their career and the
key is just getting started and not
waiting or trying to get perfection if
you keep those trade-offs in mind and
kind of consciously know what you're
moving into then at least you're getting
there now you know that the first thing
you do will actually have massive
downstream effects because who you get
exposed to what brand you get affiliated
with who you meet and what you actually
are working on that will become kind of
the basis of your next job and your next
job and your f-stop so yes it is very
important but at the same time it's too
easy to get paralyzed looking for
perfection versus just getting in there
and your story will evolve based on what
you're doing and it's important to you
to kind of control your career narrative
it's like here's why I did this and
here's therefore what I learned and
here's what I'm looking for